[MUSIC PLAYING]
Good afternoon, everyone,
my name's Cliff Samaniego,
and I work on the business
development team focused
on Google Play Games.
And today, we're going to
talk about understanding
and engaging with your
Google Play audience.
The foundation of
success for Google Play
is building a great game.
But how do users know
what's a great game
versus a mediocre game
before they download the APK?
The answer lies with
consumer ratings and reviews
that are found on every product
page listing on Google Play.
Ratings and reviews largely
shape the install and purchase
journey for users and will
help forge your success
on our platform.
Over the years, we've
seen a direct correlation
between ratings and
quality and revenue.
The game developers
that have higher ratings
will have a greater
opportunity to make
more revenue on Google Play.
So it makes sense that
you spend the time looking
at what users have
in terms of feedback
and actively managing
their feedback.
With ratings and
reviews, we also
feel that you have
a great opportunity
to talk with your most
passionate and engaged
audience.
After all, they're the ones
that are leaving you feedback
directly on Google Play.
However, the burden
that sometimes
comes with popular games
is the influx of reviews.
How can you manage all
these reviews that come in?
With 1,000 different
reviews, you're
going to see that not
all feedback is equal,
and you're going
to also experience
the good, the bad, and ugly.
However, this
shouldn't deter you
from mining that
great information
and understanding user
satisfaction and, in the end
result, making improvements
to your game quality.
We've recently announced
new improvements
that will address a lot of
these issues that you face.
That's going to allow you to
search, organize, diagnose,
as well as take
action very quickly.
Some of these
recent enhancements
include ratings over
time, where you're
going to see upswings and
downswings of ratings for a set
period of time, ratings by
device, app version, Android
version, country and
language, and more.
You're going to be
able to look at review
highlights where we're going
to bubble up common themes that
are found in the
reviews, the ability
to search through
text in reviews,
and also look at
device on a per review
basis-- device metadata
on a per review basis.
And last but not least, we
also made an enhancement
to receive notifications
for updated reviews.
Now let's take a look at
mastering ratings and reviews
with five very easy tips.
First, be sure to
always reply to reviews,
whether they are good or bad.
What you want to do is build
your community on Google Play
and make sure that they
are being listened to.
Thank them for
their suggestions.
Also let them know if any
bugs are being addressed.
Include, if you can, your email
support alias in the reply,
especially if
you're going to have
a lot of bugs that need
to be handled in mass,
and your user support
team can handle that.
If you follow these
steps, users will often
positively change their rating.
Next, make sure you're
looking at reviews
and how they change over
time, and overlay these
with your updates.
If they do coincide
with recent updates,
you're going to be able to
drill down a little bit further
to troubleshoot the issue.
Next, take advantage of our
new search functionality.
This powerful new
release is going
to allow you to run queries on
a lot of different parameters
that include ratings, language,
app version, devices, and more.
We also recently launched
review highlights,
where we're going to bubble
up common keywords that
are found in your user reviews.
This will help you drill
down on immediate needs.
It will also help you
prioritize surface topics.
These will actually be surfaced
on the product page listing,
so be sure to prioritize
these when you see them.
Last but not least, after
you've identified key themes
is to have dialogues
and take actions.
There's two tools that are
going to help you out with this.
The first is our recently
launched notifications tool.
That's going to keep you
updated any time a user has
amended their feedback or
their ratings or comments.
Also, set alerts
within the developer
console, and that'll
keep you informed
of any swings in terms of
crashes, installs, and ratings.
Thank you very much.
And, hopefully, you are having
a bit better understanding
of your Google Play audience.
And with that, I'd like to
introduce Mark Chambers.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]